please welcome Tyler Perry
you
they just saved my name at the Oscars
hey I better enjoy cuz it'll probably
never happen again big a film editor
involves choices for example I could
choose to show myself in a close-up
what's up guys now this is what is
generally done with actresses and actors
up to that point in their careers where
it close up gets a bit scary without a
special lens $300,000 worth of lighting
and the most creative special effects
since avatar that was a joke haha okay
alright at that point the choice could
be to go to a medium shot medium shot
guys flattering yet no pressure to be
perfect now the editor could choose a
wide shot but I personally like being
the center of attention so I'll stick
with the medium shot that's what I would
do or you could even do a wide shot of
the audience or I could show you what
the hosts are doing backstage right now
I wanted to get even cuz Alec Baldwin
keeps walking up to me saying man I
loved you in The Blind Side that wasn't
me that wasn't me so that is what a film
editor does they make choices while
composing a film here are the nominees
for best film editing Steven Rifkin John
refuel and James Cameron for avatar
Julianne Clarke for district 9
Bob Moravsky and Chris Ennis for The
Hurt Locker
Sally Mickey four glorious bastards Joe
clocks were precious based on the novel
push by Sapphire and the winner is The
Hurt Locker Bob Moravsky and prisoner
this is the first Academy Award a
nomination for Bob Murawski and Chris
Innes
it's definitely the night to be here a
tribute to horror films and now Roger
Corman nods unbelievable and my wife
thanks to my color bomb Morosky my
amazing husband and to sam raimi who
gave us both our first cutting jobs to
kathryn bigelow Mark Boal all our
amazing crew our assistant Sean Vala
rupert lloyd my mom who's here in the
audience everybody just loved you guys
and thanks for and and thank thank you
to the Academy for giving this award to
a movie that was made without
compromised we didn't have any preview
screenings or focus groups or studio
notes we just everybody made the movie
we wanted to make and it turned out
great so I'm glad everybody liked it
thank you
you